[Applause]
[Music]
you know we're getting near the end of
summer now but there's still time to
cram in one more destination vacation
this week's games can take you to in the
football stadiums all around the US and
even prison maybe you don't want that
last one but if you hit that subscribe
button you'll hear about some other
lovely options when new releases goes
live every Sunday now here are some of
the finest selections for you this week
Nathan Drake story may be over but
uncharted the Lost legacy keeps the
adventuring spirit alive this standalone
chapter puts you in the shoes of Chloe
Fraser finally getting the spotlight
after completely missing a thief's end
she and uncharted 4 villain Nadine will
explore the Western Ghats in India
searching for the legendary Tusk of
Ganesh at this point you know what to
expect from an uncharted game but
getting to experience all the running
jumping shooting action as Chloe sounds
pretty awesome you can take her for a
spin only on ps4 on Tuesday August 22nd
but if you want to refresh yourself on
the series first why not check out our
in-depth history of Uncharted the
Uncharted series has its fair share of
prison breaks and that's what The
Escapist 2 is all about this time
however you can plan your escape with
friends you'll have to use floors roofs
vents and tunnels to get out but you'll
have to juggle actual prison routines
too don't forget to line up or do your
day job if you think you can make it out
you can lock yourself into The Escapist
2 on ps4 Xbox one and PC on the 22nd
with a Nintendo switch version planned
for later I probably don't need to
explain Madden 18 or even football to
any of you unless you're one of our
international viewers in which case you
can already tell by the video that I'm
talking about American football so
what's new this year
Madden 18 has a new robust story mode
that takes cues from FIFA's the journey
and it's the first game in the series to
run on the Frostbite engine you can
huddle up on ps4 and Xbox one on Friday
the 25th oh yeah the cover star is
Patriots Tom Brady
football players can perform some pretty
superhuman feats on the field but if you
want a real superhero experience
check out Megaton rainfall this
first-person hero game lets you walk the
earth and fly around looking for threats
from the bottom of the ocean to the top
of the stratosphere the stronger you
become the farther you'll be able to fly
visiting the moon and even the surface
of the Sun it's coming to ps4 which
means you can also pop on a PS VR
headset to really experience what it's
like to be a superhero no not like that
Megaton rainfall launches on Saturday
the 26th now let's rewind a bit raid
world war 2 is pretty easy to sum up
picture the payday games but instead of
robbing jewelry stores you're sneaking
into Nazi encampments and pulling off
espionage missions this co-op shooter
will take your rogue unit all over
Europe bringing down the Third Reich
from within it's less about historical
accuracy and more about the action and
you can drop in on PC on the 26th with
console releases coming later this fall
and those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching guys and I'll
be back with more games next week